Informed consent stands for the rights of
patients and is a key part of the clinical
research process.
In this lecture, we will review the process
of obtaining informed consent and how to inform
patients about being a clinical trial subject.
Informed consent is the process through which
researchers provide the necessary information
to potential participants so that a knowledgeable
decision can be made about whether the individuals
wish to take part in a research study.
It is an ongoing process that begins with
initial recruitment of subjects, and continues
after the initial oral or written agreement
form from an individual to participate in
a research study.
Upon getting familiar with all the information
related to the clinical trial, the patient
has the option to decide whether he or she
wants to participate in a study.
If they agreed to do so, an administrative
procedure is completed and the patient becomes
a clinical trial subject.
Let's review the differences between being
a patient and being a subject.
As we mentioned, when a person volunteers
to participate in a research trial, his or
her status changes from patient to subject.
A subject in a clinical trial is an individual
who participates in a clinical trial either
as a recipient of the investigation of products
or as a control.
The subjects may not be receiving standard
of care as patients do.
The risks related with the treatment may be
higher.
Documentation for subjects is more extensive
than regular clinical documentation.
Finally, the subject is the ultimate decision-maker
and must have complete information to assure
his participation remains voluntary.
In general, there are 5 steps in obtaining
an informed consent.
Step one of the process is introduction.
The Investigator must introduce himself or
herself to the potential subject and the proposed
study.
Step two, an explanation.
The Investigator, must explain the study to
the potential subject, providing all pertinent
information such as purpose, procedures, risks,
benefits, alternatives to participation, and
etc.
Step three, comprehension.
The potential subject may be provided with
a study information sheet and must be afforded
sufficient time to consider whether or not
to participate in the research.
Step four, question and answer session.
After allowing the potential subject time
to read the study information sheet, the Investigator
must answer any additional questions the potential
subject may have and may obtain verbal agreement
to participate in the research.
And, step five, obtaining consent.
The following video will demonstrate how an
informed consent
can
be taken.